شوارع شبه خاليه ومتاجر ومدارس مغلقه
اجراءات تذكروا بزمن كوفيت هنا في بكين
فرضت السلطات الصينيه قيودا بسبب تزايد
الاصابات وهي حاصله قريبه من ذروه
الاصابات اليوميه المسجله في ابريل الماضي
بينما تجنبت العاصمه حتى الان الخضوع
لاغلاق الشمل فرضت اجراءاته اغلاق على
ابنيه محدده بينما الصف السكان في توابير
لاجراء فحوص كوفيت قبل الدخول الى الاماكن
العامه من جهتها وصفت السلطات الصينيه
نقدر بعض المدن
في السنوات الثلاث الماضيه
في السكان لتتبخر الاهمال في سرعه اعاده
الفتح ما بعد الجائحه
تتمسكوا ثاني قوه اقتصاديه في العالم بي
سياسه صفر كوزيت عبر فرد تدابير اغلاق
مفاجئه وعمليه فحص مكثفه ويا سياسه نجحت
في المراحل الاولى من انتشار الفيروس لكن
لموجه الاصابات الاخيره تشكل اختبار لمدى
امكانيات هذه السياسه على الصمت